now Scott Smith the father of the high
school girl whose rape was covered up
came on this show last year to tell us
this heartbreaking story my daughter was
sexually assaulted at the end of school
in May of last year and um
you know I went to the school board
meeting you know to see what was going
on another parent activist
you know approached my wife and started
antagonizing her then I tried to tell
the lady what had happened to my
daughter and she looked me dead in the
face and said that's not what happened
the next thing I know I'm getting
touched from all over the place the
police
are grabbing me and next thing I know
I'm tackled to the ground
[Music]
joining me now Scott Smith the man you
just saw get tackled and arrested while
trying to get answers about the rape of
his daughter on school property the
world truly is upside down also with me
is Ian Pryor executive director of fight
for schools Scott now that you've seen
um bits and pieces of this grand jury
report
takes my breath away what they did to
conceal the truth and to shuttle this
kid on to commit other crimes your
reaction tonight
you know the the grand jury report
pretty much told us what we already knew
you know
my family's lived through this for
almost 18 months now
everything that was pretty much in the
grand jury report we've spoke out on
we've exposed
and you didn't have the emails you
didn't have the internal communication
we had a few yeah
um
and um
you know the fact that it didn't come
out with any teeth though you know
there's nobody held accountable by name
you know that whole report laid out a
bunch of
you know
misdeeds uh criminal you know situations
perhaps and at the end of the report you
know we get six recommendations of
things that they should do better next
time
you know I I hope that the grand jury is
not done with their Duty yet and I hope
that this has more teeth in it I don't
think they're done with this Ian at all
I mean as a former criminal defense
lawyer uh here's how the vice chair of
the school board reacted we're pleased
that the special Grand jury's extension
investigation found no evidence of
criminal conduct on the part of anyone
with an lcps and not a single indictment
was filed as a result of this lengthy
process and is that an accurate
portrayal of this report is this just
now just over yeah no it's not an
accurate portrayal and I I dare to say I
don't think that the school board
actually read the press release from the
attorney general that said the grand
jury has not been discharged and so what
I see when I look at this report I don't
see negligence I don't see gross
negligence I see Reckless indifference
and when you're looking at things like
neglect of a minor delinquency of a
minor contributing to delinquency of
minor recklessness is the standard and
so I also know that in there going
through all this Behavior by the school
administration they also talked about
the lawyer for the school and and
they've seemed like they really wanted
to indict him for tampering with a
witness but they don't have a tampering
a witness tampering Statute in Virginia
so they said you know we looked these
but it doesn't fit obstruction uh for a
con indictment for the lawyer but they
didn't say that about the actual
substance of the report and they didn't
say that about obstruction for the
school board members why wouldn't they
say that so I suspect we could see more
down the road in the very near future
and I think that that email that
statement if I'm a grand juror and I see
that that tells me they either didn't
read it they read it they didn't care
but they are not getting it yeah oh the
obstruction question is very very
interesting now Scott the grand jury
also noted that when I asked about the
individual wearing a skirt in the female
bathroom which is a biological male of
course the rapist these school board
members were quick to claim that he was
instead wearing a kilt
Scott they just don't stop playing
politics here
no they don't they just lie lie lie
um I mean I I can show you the picture
of what he looked like that day it's on
my phone right now in my pocket there
was no Kilt about it
does he was he always dressed this way
was this just a way to get in the
bathroom that moment do we know I think
he decided who he was and what he was on
a daily basis
um you know I've seen I've seen evidence
since that unfortunately you know my
wife and I you know we we fought very
hard you know to get this child
treatment
and then you know evidence was revealed
to us after the fact that you know this
this kid's a psychopath he's a sexual
predator unfortunately we're going to
hear about him again
Ann Ziegler the superintendent why is he
still in this position why is he still
there that's a great question and you
know after reading that we need names
everyone needs everyone in this case has
a name by the way and a face I mean
after reading that grand jury report
I don't know how the school board cannot
fire him I mean what are they afraid of
does he have something on them that
maybe wasn't disclosed to the grand jury
that he's going to go talk about if they
fire him but I will say tonight the
Loudoun County Board of Supervisors met
and the chairwoman of the Board of
Supervisors a Democrat repeatedly called
for the school board to fire Scott
Ziegler she said he needs to be fired
tonight this is not a political issue
this is not Democrat Republican he and
his senior staff need to go this I mean
the fact that this has gone on for as
long as it has is mind-blowing I mean
people have been watching this car our
coverage of this for now over a year
Scott you told your story I I want to
just ball crying I was so upset by it
and you as a parent I can't I first of
all I want to I want to thank you for
your bravery for speaking out and being
as tough as you've been and and you've
just done such amazing work on this all
the parents but thank you for you and
your family for standing strong and I
hope you I hope you have a good
plaintiff's lawyer because you got you
this is a major major litigation which
should follow here speaking as a former
lawyer all right we thank you both for
joining us I appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else